Prof: Good morning.
Now we move to our last author
in this course,
to Émile Durkheim.
There are really two Durkheims.
We have seen certainly two
Marxs and two Webers.
There are also two faces of
Émile Durkheim.
To put it bluntly,
the young Durkheim has been a
functionalist and a positivist,
and then late in his life he
has--his epistemological turn--
he became a cultural analyst.
Well it's not quite true,
because each author is more
complex, and there were already
elements of his culturalism in
the early work.
But there was certainly a
dramatic change in the way how
Durkheim conceived what the job
of social sciences,
later in his life,
in his book The Elementary
Forms of Religious Life.
I think it had a lot to do also
with his personal life,
and we will talk about this.
He was brought up in a
rabbinical family and was
supposed to become a rabbi,
and then he revolted against
the parental household--
much like Nietzsche did--and
turned probably into an atheist,
but certainly not an active
believer in Judaism.
And later in his life he became
again interested in religion,
and not only philosophically,
but also existentially
interested in religion.
Well in the course we have only
four lectures on Durkheim.
So I'll leave Durkheim the
culturalist out,
and we will be doing work only
on his earlier work,
The Division of Labor,
the wonderful book
Suicide,
and a somewhat difficult book,
The Rules of Sociological
Method.
And I'll just leave The
Elementary Forms of Religious
Life;
I don't have time to fit this
into.
Durkheim had an extraordinary
impact on American social
science.
Initially it was particularly
the younger Durkheim,
the functionalist Durkheim,
who had such an extraordinary
impact.
Unlike Weber or Marx,
whose impact was broad and
affected history and economics
and political science,
Durkheim's impact was much more
focused on sociology.
So in this course the only
author who, properly speaking,
is a sociologist is
Émile Durkheim.
All the others you discussed
were not really identified
themselves as sociologists.
Later in his life Weber did,
but not on the whole.
Émile Durkheim
identified himself and his
project as sociology.
It, of course,
has a lot to do that these
disciplinary boundaries between
economics,
political science,
and sociology became much more
sharply drawn by the end of the
nineteenth and early twentieth
century,
and sociology as an academic
discipline was really
established by the late
nineteenth century.
So this is Émile
Durkheim--born in 1858 and died
in 1917.
Just very briefly about his
life.
He was born in a small town,
Épinal in France.
As I said, his father was a
rabbi and he was expected to
become a rabbi himself.
In '79, he was admitted to the
École Normale
Supérieure,
which is one of these very
elite schools,
MIT version in France,
and by the time he went to
university--
École Normale
Supérieure is a
university--
he lost his religious beliefs.
He was for some time a
professor at the University of
Bordeaux.
Then he became politically
active in the 1940s,
especially in the so-called
Dreyfus Affair;
and I will just briefly mention
what that was.
Then in 1902,
he became professor at the
University of Paris,
which is not quite as
distinguished as École
Normale Supérieure.
His son was killed in the war,
and shortly after this he died
in Paris.
So this is Alfred Dreyfus.
This is a very important event
in French, and in many ways in
European, history.
What was the Dreyfus Affair?
You probably all know.
In 1894, Dreyfus,
who was Jewish,
was falsely accused to be a
German spy, and was imprisoned.
That was obviously an
anti-Semitic trial,
and this mobilized the French
intellectuals,
and not only French
but French intellectuals in
particular.
Émile Zola,
whom some of you may have read,
the leading French writer of
this epoch,
wrote an important article
which appeared in the leading
French daily newspaper:
J'Accuse--
"I accuse the French
judiciary of being
anti-Semitic."
Well Durkheim joined other
prominent French intellectuals
to protest the trial.
It took them a long time but
eventually they were successful.
Dreyfus was eventually
exonerated of all charges and
made a Knight of the Legion of
Honor.
So it was a happy ending of
French anti-Semitism,
for awhile.
Then it came back with
vengeance during the occupation,
Nazi occupation.
The French are not as innocent
about anti-Semitism as you may
want to believe it.
Many were collaborating with
the Nazis.
Well about the work.
In '93 he wrote a dissertation,
which probably is still his
most influential book,
The Division of Labor in
Society,
and today's lecture will be
focused on this.
'95, it was followed by
The Rules of
Sociological Method,
which is his most positivistic
statement.
The Division of Labor is
his most functionalist work.
And then in '97 he wrote
Suicide.
Suicide is a very
important book because it's
really the first piece of
rigorous empirical social
science,
which takes a very unusual,
very rare phenomenon,
like suicide,
and crunches numbers extremely
carefully to test whether he can
identify social determinants of
such a rare phenomenon.
Fortunately even in countries
where many people commit
suicide, it's still a rare
phenomenon.
But he managed to come up with
a very provocative theory,
what he demonstrated with very
careful empirical analysis.
We will be looking at two parts
of The Division of Labor.
Today we will be looking at the
major arguments of Division
of Labor.
And then also we will look at,
Thursday,
on his theory of anomie,
which is a central piece of the
book,
Division of Labor,
but a kind of by-the-way
analysis.
And, as I said,
in 1915 he wrote this book,
The Elementary Forms of
Religious Life,
which is a major break in his
work,
and shows his renewed interest
in the spiritual and the
metaphysical.
Okay, just very briefly,
what is in the books.
As I said, The
Division of Labour was
his Ph.D.
dissertation.
But unlike many scholars whose
only good book is their
dissertation,
Durkheim followed it up with a
number of good other books.
Many professors are actually
one book people,
or at least they should have
been, because their only good
book was the dissertation and
what they published later only
published because 'publish or
perish'--
right?--to get tenure;
that's why they probably
published too many books.
Anyway, he was inspired by
Montesquieu.
Well Durkheim is very French,
and his roots are deeply in
Montesquieu, and to some extent
in Rousseau;
he admired Rousseau as well.
But Montesquieu is really the
major inspiration behind him.
And well what he does,
he uses law as a measure of
social development--
much like Montesquieu did,
sort of--
and he explains,
by using the law,
the legal system how the
division of labor evolved,
what were the stages of the
development of division of
labor.
Well just a very brief
contrast.
Right?
Marx was interested in economic
conflict--right?--in struggle
around scarce economic
resources.
Weber was interested in
struggle for power.
So was Nietzsche.
Durkheim was interested in
social solidarity.
Marx and Weber are conflict
theorists.
They try to explain what breaks
up society.
Durkheim is a theorist which
tries to understand what holds
society together,
what brings us together,
why society is not falling
apart.
Right?
Well in the book he makes a
crucial distinction between two
types of solidarity:
mechanical and organic
solidarity.
And I will speak about this at
great length.
This is another attempt to
develop a typology of evolution
of societies.
You are already familiar with
Marx's modes of
production--right?--the
evolution from slavery to
feudalism to capitalism.
You are familiar with Max
Weber: traditional authority and
legal-rational authority.
Now Durkheim's alternative is
mechanical and organic
solidarity.
Right?
What Weber called traditional
authority is kind of mechanical
solidarity for Durkheim;
or what Marx called
pre-capitalist formations is
mechanical solidarity.
Organic solidarity described
legal-rational authority or
modernity or capitalism.
Well he also identified
pathological forms of division
of labor, and this is what he
called anomie.
And his idea of anomie is a
kind of similar or analogous
distinction,
what was alienation in Marx and
what was disenchantment in
Weber--
though there are very important
differences as well,
and I will be talking about
this Thursday.
Now on Suicide--as I
said, this is one of the first
very rigorous empirical studies
of a social phenomenon--
a phenomenon we think is not
quite social,
we think it is really an
individual decision whether you
take your life or not.
But Durkheim actually was
capable to show that even in
this very private action,
when you take your life,
there are social determinants,
who is committing suicide or
not.
And he's making a distinction
between different types of
suicide--
anomic, altruistic,
egoistic and fatalistic ones--
and I will be talking about
this after you return from
Thanksgiving's break.
Now about the methodology.
He was a methodological
collectivist,
much like Montesquieu or
Rousseau, and very much unlike
Hobbes, Locke or Mills;
you know, Marx being kind of
halfway between methodological
individualism and collectivism.
As a theorist of revolutionary
consciousness,
he was a methodological
collectivist.
We will see Durkheim's notion
of collective conscience is not
all that different from Marx's
idea of class consciousness,
which is not the sum
total--right?--
of the individual consciousness
of workers.
But Marx, in his theory of
exploitation,
as you have read his text,
reads almost like Adam Smith,
or John Stuart Mill.
Right?
It's self-interested,
rational individuals,
from which he explains the
nature of exploitation.
Well it's much more difficult
to figure out how Weber fits
into these categories.
I think he's also vacillating
between collectivism and
individualism.
Later in his life he's becoming
more of a methodological
individualist.
But Durkheim,
the consistency in Durkheim,
is that from day one he's a
methodological collectivist,
and remains a methodological
collectivist.
But at the same time he
believed in the existence of
social facts,
and that social facts,
on the other hand,
can be observed with rigorous
empirical methodology;
and this is what makes him,
in a way, a positivist.
So this is just a brief
introduction to who the author
is.
And now let me move to the
division of labor.
>
Well my computer is getting
slower, as the semester is
progressing.
So it's probably time for the
semester to end,
because my laptop,
though it is new,
it still will become unbearably
slow by the end of the semester.
Okay, so this is Émile
Durkheim and the division of
labor in society.
So how does Durkheim proceed in
the work?
And today's presentation will
focus on the question why
Durkheim begins the analysis by
taking the law as the point of
departure.
And then we will proceed how he
makes the distinction between
organic and mechanical
solidarity.
So the question actually is,
for a methodological
collectivist,
that you need to find some
collective expression,
in order to study society--not
individuals.
And much like Montesquieu,
he believes that the law is
such a collective phenomenon;
law, which can be studied and
established without studying
individual views or individual
opinions.
Right?
It's parts of what--Durkheim's
terminology is the collective
conscience, and which is above
individual consciousnesses.
Okay, so that's--what are the
most important issues in the
work, as far as we'll discuss it
today?
Well he's interested in
solidarity.
As I pointed out,
we are--his real question is
what holds society together?
We are so different,
societies should fall apart.
Right?
He is writing in the late
nineteenth, early twentieth
century.
This is the time of
industrialization,
of urbanization.
People are dislodged from their
traditional communities,
from the traditional villages,
pushed away from peasant
agriculture,
and move into urban industrial
employment.
And the question is will
society break down,
will social order break down,
if the traditional order does
not keep us together?
And this is what he tries to
figure out;
what in a modern urban and
industrial society can keep us
together?
And he tries to find solidarity.
And well what creates this
solidarity is collective
consciousness.
And the fundamental idea in
Durkheim about collective
consciousness--
as I said, it is analogous to
the notion of the general will
in Rousseau,
or the notion of class
consciousness in Marx.
So therefore it is not the sum
total of individual
consciousnesses,
but something of shared norms,
beliefs and values,
which exist prior an individual
is being born,
prior society actually existed,
which is passed on from one
generation to the other.
Right?
And therefore he tries to
show--right?--these collective
consciousnesses which persist
over time.
And, of course,
the most obvious,
most rigorous way to go about
this, to look at law.
Because that's exactly what the
law is.
Right?
The law is changing over time,
but usually the change is very
slow and reaches over several
generations.
So for somebody who is a French
social scientist,
and one unique--we already
talked about this.
Well the French are very
methodological collectivists.
The Anglo-Saxons tend to be
methodological individualists.
And the French,
unlike the Germans,
are very scientifique;
they are very much scientists.
The word scientifique in
German does not exist.
The Germans say,
"I'm
Wissenschaftler";
Wissenschaft
means--Wissen is
knowledge.
Science in German is
constituted by all sorts of
knowledge.
Right?
It's a much broader notion.
In French, or in English,
with science we really mean
rigorous science of the natural
science types.
Well Durkheim did not go as far
as saying it is natural science.
But certainly he was very
scientifique in
insistence of rigorous analysis
of objective data.
Right?
That's what--why the
Germans--Wiss
enschaftler,
all those who study ideas are
Wissenschaftlers.
It's a much broader notion.
Natural scientists are also
Wissenschaftlers.
But people who study humanities
and history of ideas are also
Wissenschaftlers.
People who are an expert on
Hobbes and spend their life
writing on Hobbes is a
Wissenschaftler
--right?--in German.
We can hardly say somebody who
does--right?--history of ideas
to be a scientist.
Right?
We are iffy.
We call it humanities.
We talk about social sciences
with a lot of anxiety,
and real scientists ask us,
"Social science,
what do you mean?
What is science about what you
are doing?"
Well those of you who take
economics, they make sure it
looks like science,
because you have all the
equations on the blackboard.
So therefore a scientist can
relax.
But if you are listening to my
lectures, and not a single
equation on the blackboard,
you probably have doubt that
this is really social science.
Anyway, he was
scientifique,
in the sense of being very
rigorous in his analysis.
Sort of what is collective
consciousness--I give here a
citation for you.
Right?
It is a totality of beliefs and
sentiments which are common to
the average member of
society--right?--but which has a
life of its own.
Right?
That's what he calls collective
consciousness.
So this is different from the
consciousnesses of the
individuals;
though he's a scientist. Right?
He's scientifique.
It has to be realized in
individuals.
So therefore,
I mean, Durkheim would not
necessarily be opposed to carry
out even survey research,
and ask individuals about their
customs or values,
and sort of aggregate this up
and try to find those patterns,
especially over time and across
nations.
That's not really what he did.
But I think he would be open
for this kind of research,
which, of course,
made him so influential in
early American sociology in the
1930s,
'40s and '50s,
because American sociology has
been very positivist and very
empirical.
Well but the most obvious
example of collective conscience
is the law--probably also the
language.
Well there are differences in
law in pre-modern and modern
societies.
Now we are getting into--he's
building the argument up to make
the distinction between
mechanical and organic
solidarity.
And let me just go through of
this.
<<technical
adjustment>>
So the argument is then in
pre-modern societies the law
which existed is primarily a
repressive or penal law.
Well there is--the purpose of
punishment is to punish evil
behavior.
And we tend to agree what is
evil behavior is,
and punishments therefore also
tends to be harsh,
to prevent further aggressive
behavior by individuals.
So this is the legal system of
pre-modern societies.
Well I will give you a couple
of citations,
and I won't read them.
I will put them on the internet
and you can read it at your
leisure.
It kind of elaborates on the
points what I made.
Okay, but in modern society the
legal system is very different.
The legal system is based on
contract;
the essence of modern legal
system is contract.
It's not that we do not have a
penal code--right?--the penal
code survives.
But what is novel is
contractual law,
which is restitutive;
which is not about punishing
evil, but simply restitute the
damage somebody,
by breaking a contract,
caused to the other contracting
partner.
Right?
And he said,
well this is a new type of law
which emerges with modernity.
Marx would say it is a new
legal system which emerges with
legal--
with capitalism,
and Weber would say this is the
essence of legal-rational
authority.
Well why does he study law?
I don't want to elaborate on
this too long.
That's obvious-- that the legal
system is the single best
measure of what he tries to get
at,
collective conscience,
which can be studied the most
objectively.
Right?
There are law books and legal
practices and minutes of
recordings how the courts
operated,
and how law was made and
implemented,
which can be studied with a
great level of rigor.
For instance,
it's very easy to study whether
indeed contractual law is a new
form of law.
You can go back to legal
history and to establish exactly
when contractual law emerged.
This was actually also very
much on the mind of the young
Weber,
when he was also looking at
basically the emergence of
contractual law in late medieval
Italy,
in his Ph.D.
for the law degree.
I think I already made this
point, what is interesting,
that Durkheim and Weber sort of
ignored each other.
I don't think they ever cited
each other.
I don't recall ever seeing a
citation to one another,
though they were working on the
same area.
Of course, they both did speak
both of the languages,
and they were,
of course, aware that the other
giant exists.
They were probably,
in many ways,
too close--too much in
competition with each other--to
cite each other.
I mentioned already that
Durkheim did review Marianne
Weber's book,
but never any of Weber's books,
though Marianne was writing--
right?--about marriage law,
which was of marginal interest
to Durkheim,
and Weber was writing on
religion, which was so central
for Durkheim's interests.
Nevertheless they kind of
ignored each other.
Now about the two types of
solidarity.
Well mechanical
solidarity--it's hard to
remember the distinction.
One would think organic
solidarity must be
old--right?--and mechanical must
be modern, the machines.
Now the opposite is true.
I kept making these mistakes
for the first two or three years
when I was reading Durkheim,
some forty-five years ago.
Well mechanical solidarity is
which describes pre-modern
societies, and this is a
solidarity which is based on the
similarities of the parts.
Well this is why you can have a
penal law, because a penal law
does not make a distinction
between contractual partners;
it assumes a sameness of the
group as such.
And mechanical
solidarity--right?--as I said,
is primarily based that we see
ourselves similar in the group.
Organic solidarity,
so will Durkheim argue,
is one which is based on
differences in society.
A higher level of division of
labor in society produces
organic solidarity.
Organic, he meant,
it is a kind of biological
analogy.
Modern societies,
like the human body.
Right?
There are functional
differences between the human
organs.
That's why it is organic
solidarity.
Right?
The heart performs a different
function than the lung,
but the lung could not live
without the heart.
Right?
This is why this is organic
solidarity.
Society operates more like an
organism.
In earlier times,
society was more operating like
a machine where you actually--a
part is taken out,
mechanically it doesn't matter
all that much.
Right?
It is a simple machine, I mean.
So that's the fundamental
distinction.
By the way, also for
Durkheim--and this is also in
the text what you are reading--
this distinction between
mechanical and organic
solidarity is developed in order
to describe societies as such.
But much like Weber's notion of
traditional authority and
legal-rational authority,
he is also using this to
understand society--
social solidarities in
contemporary life.
So mechanical solidarity does
exist in contemporary society as
well.
And he makes this reference to
finding a marital partner,
whom we want to date with,
and whom we consider to marry.
And occasionally we are--we try
to find somebody who is more
similar than we are,
and people will say,
"Well you look
like"--
if you are
heterosexual--"like
brothers and sisters".
Or if you are gay,
"Well you look like
brothers"
or "You look like
sisters."
Right?
You look the same,
you look similar.
And that can be--right?--a
consideration for a lasting
partnership.
I'm trying to find somebody who
likes the same stuff what I
like, who is like me.
Right?
But it can be the opposite as
well.
Right?
You may be looking for a
person--you may follow the logic
of organic solidarity,
right?--you may be looking for
a person who will complement
you.
Right?
I'm bad in keeping the books,
and therefore what I am trying
to look for is somebody who will
balance the checkbook.
Right?
So occasionally looking for a
partner, we are looking for
somebody who will complement us.
Now that
describes--right?--modern
society, with a higher level of
division of labor.
Division of labor,
he said, can bring us together,
much like the bodily organism,
that we are performing
different functions in society.
We complement each other--we
need each other--on the basis of
our differences,
rather than our similarities.
And, in fact,
the contractual law expresses
the spirit of organic solidarity
as such.
Well Durkheim will show us that
there is, in fact,
a lot of trouble in the
transition from mechanical to
organic solidarity;
and this is what he will call
anomie.
In the transition from
mechanical to organic
solidarity,
moving from a traditional
society to a modern society,
our value system breaks down,
we find ourselves in the
situation of anomie.
But this is a topic I will be
talking about Thursday.
Thank you very much.